so how long have you been doing this for
about 11 years but especially in the
last two
i've done 3000. that is amazing
have you learned anything from them oh
i've learned so much
i mean from doing these interviews
i've learned that hate and judgment are
addictions
for a lot of people i've learned that
our childhoods play a gigantic role in
our adult lives
i've learned that i think what's missing
more than anything
in our lives is courage
integrity which requires
there's so many things i've learned and
i continue to learn
every every day every week i do these
and i love learning so i just keep keep
doing these
so angel where did you grow up so
i'm from ventura county north of l.a
yeah just a little bit it's absolutely
beautiful the beach
mountains the scenery is breathtaking um
i could take you to the most beautiful
places that would change your life like
spiritually
and you would not expect it the thing is
is that
with the beauty there's a lot of pain
and darkness and
i'm from a little part of ventura county
called santa paula and
back then there was not one black family
that lived there it was crazy i hadn't
even seen a black person before
until i was like maybe six um
whole childhood up until i was about
nine
i know for a fact shaped me to be
the person i am today and that was the
start of it
the way my thea explains it is that i
wasn't given the right tools
you know my mom i don't even call her
mom that's heidi
um my father i call him the sperm donor
he doesn't even get his
first name i'm the oldest of nine
children
from different parents different
families different even races
and i was the one that paved the way for
everybody else
i can tell you a million things
i think that the biggest thing is
that today i love my life but it wasn't
always like that
going from my mother watching her go
through her sex addiction
and alcoholism after being abused by my
sperm donor
you know our whole childhood i watched
her get beat so
badly and i couldn't save her
i couldn't even save myself couldn't
save my brothers
i watched him roll my baby sister who
wasn't
his off the bed and she was only two
months old
my whole entire life has just been a
huge wreck
and at the same time it has been so
beautiful
i like to see the glasses half full as
best i can
but i am bipolar depressant and it
doesn't help that
everything just goes to [ __ ] every day
it doesn't matter how hard i try
anything like that
at 13 i lost my virginity only because
my mother told me it was okay
she lost her virginity at 13 and i
wanted to be like her so bad i thought
she was
superwoman watching her come out of that
relationship
get divorced and get her life together
or so i thought was together
that really
really made me like glorify a certain
lifestyle
without a father without a mother really
i just had like a road dog my whole life
that was just my real dog and i was
always her wing woman
i lost my virginity to a 19 year old guy
i did not know i met him
for five minutes and that was it i said
[ __ ] it
from that moment on i have
always always chased that
that feeling that i thought i was
getting and that feeling was
this person wants me this person adores
me this person loves me in some kind of
way
shape or form they want me and that
right there it was a
freeing type feeling it made me feel
acceptable even and that's really sad
my addictions are so sporadic it's
ridiculous
i have a sex addiction really badly
which i am grateful that i'm married to
a woman who totally understands me my
best friend
i've struggled with my drug addiction
because it made me feel like superwoman
it numbed all of my
pain or at least helped me cope with the
innocence
i when i'm high i don't cry as easily
i'm able to brush it off you could say
whatever you want you could beat me you
could rate me you could steal
me it doesn't matter i'm still going to
give you the shirt off my back
and i'm okay with that i chased this
really disgusting dream that
if i made sure that i gave you
everything that i had and i made you
love me
it would it would help me but it never
helped
that's why when i got pregnant with my
first child
my first of three i was 15
and i was kicked out for stealing my
mom's van
thinking i was cool she kicked me out
and i went up there and i got pregnant
by this guy i did not even know his real
name
he called himself michi that's a
nickname
i still don't know where that man is he
never came to see my son
my son's name is jeremiah ari that is
appointed lion of god
he saved my life he is
the light that i look for but
unfortunately i didn't give him the
tools either
i didn't know what tools to give i
wasn't handed them in the first place
after that i met my second baby's father
who i
fell madly in love with had two children
with him
slowly got back into this really sick
twisted
insanity hamster wheel that i couldn't
get off
drugs that was the first thing i started
was with him
i felt so liberated free
able to be who i thought i was
strong confident
and i wasn't but with him i felt loved
my daughter lily nicole beautiful little
girl
and nathaniel james my little boy
they all watched me get abused by this
man
abused badly cheated on raped
even if i didn't want to
he beat me so badly i woke up in an
ambulance
with a neck brace black eye busted
ribbon concussion and i didn't remember
how it happened and when i was told and
i saw the videos
i i saw the ugliness of the man that i
thought i wanted to be with for the rest
of my life
three days later i get picked up for a
warrant
for my own arrest as a witness to my own
beating
i was not served any paperwork i wasn't
told i had to go to court i didn't know
they took me to jail my first time and
they took my babies
they took jeremiah and lily
and
i never got my daughter back
there's so much in between three years
of battling
my addiction trying to stay clean going
to na meetings
trying to reunify with my kids and and
trying to re connect with my family who
looked at me as a monster
what mother leaves their kids for all
the stuff that i had to do
i thought i was doing well for them that
was it
i put them in danger real danger
today i have not seen my daughter since
2016.
i don't know what she looks like what
her favorite color is
the judge told me do not take this wrong
you did everything you were supposed to
do that's why we're letting you keep
your boys
my oldest and my baby
but we cannot spend any more time trying
to reunify with your daughter
and the family that has her now is going
to adopt her and it was going to be a
closed adoption so i couldn't reopen not
my available for what i thought was the
last time
i relapsed that same day and two weeks
later i get a call from the foster
family and they invited me to our
softball game
and i think it was a test and i failed
terribly i was so high out of my mind
that really was thank you that really
was the last time i saw her
she looked so amazing at her softball
game she went second place in all of our
county
and she cried she cried because she lost
and i told her i said do you know how
many girls you beat to get here baby you
are amazing
and she looked at me and she told me
that she loved me and i don't
think she believed me when i told her i
love her back
she really i could see it in her eyes
she really believed that i loved my boys
more than her i wish today she could see
how much that tore me apart
my only baby girl the most beautiful
little thing in the world
i promise you she had dimples and this
cute little curly hair and she had this
laugh that was so infectious
i lost my mind so bad that my baby's dad
came and picked up my boys on a friday
and he was shaking me awake on a sunday
and i was in the same clothes
in a dark room in the corner and i don't
remember anything
i wasn't getting high that weekend i
didn't have the money for it i don't
know what happened
i just know that that
broke so much i couldn't even put
word on what it was that broke it was
just my spirit maybe
my soul
after that i didn't give a [ __ ] about
life i wanted everybody to feel the pain
that i felt
i took it out on ventura county terribly
and i regret it today but at the time i
needed everybody to feel the pain that i
felt
and nothing i did made it feel better no
matter how many cars i stole
no matter how many houses i broke into
no matter how many stores i stole from
or stole things to give to the poor or
steal from the connect to give to
everybody else it didn't matter if i
beat the girl if that was jacking her
mom or anything good or bad nothing made
me feel better
i just knew that i [ __ ] up
so badly and there was nothing i could
do to fix it
i made it worse and worse and worse
and then when i went to jail it was like
a breath of fresh air i could finally
sleep
i was safe in a box but i was safe
i wasn't worried about getting raped by
some guy walking by me
i wasn't afraid of anything i just felt
okay going to prison
was probably the best thing that ever
happened to me and i could
never ever ever ever regret that and
that's [ __ ] up to say but two and a
half years of my life
i shaped myself
i love who i am today although i did
some really
really terrible things i took girls and
i put them on the street
because i couldn't put myself there to
make that money
i just really [ __ ] up things
to people i loved because
i felt like they deserved it revenge
maybe
i still think today that i would have my
daughter if it wasn't for my mom sending
her back to foster care
we fought so hard for her to get placed
her and my son while i was pregnant with
nathaniel
we fought hard and hard and hard and
just because we got into a small
argument she sent my daughter back to
foster
the very next day and didn't even tell
me or tell her
a heads up but kept my son
that could have changed everything
although it is my fault that she got
took there's nothing i could do about
that
i shouldn't have been in that position i
should have left the first time he hit
me
i should have left the first time the
cops came
anything i did nothing i stuck and
fought in everything thinking i was
doing the right thing by sticking by my
my man my soon-to-be husband
i fought so hard for a dream that did
not exist and i lost her
but my mother that
very selfish old woman she sent my
daughter back
just to pin me in the heart
kept my son to prove a point
we still fight about that today we
actually just argued about that
yesterday
and that that to me
it is what it is that's how i feel now
is that if
you don't fight to be in my circle why
am i gonna fight to keep you anymore
i want people who want me there
but everybody has a job i fight for my
position
i work really hard to support my wife
who has a broken back
can't really too much herself i have my
13 year old and that's the only one i
have right now
because that same man that didn't even
fight for the kids in the first place
as soon as they gave me back my kids he
went behind my back and got full custody
of my baby
saying that i was out of my mind and i
couldn't take care of him
took him to south carolina and i haven't
seen him since before i went to prison
i went to prison in 2018.
i've only talked to him maybe in two
hands
he turned seven this year and i didn't
even get to talk to him for his birthday
the thing that keeps me going right now
as
badly as i want to throw the towel in
i'm exhausted
i'm hungry for for some kind of sanity
some kind of peace even for a moment a
moment of peace would be so wonderful
not a sound in the world not a song not
a breath not a heartbeat
not a car not at the wind and nothing
just a pause
i die for that inside but i never give
up
because my boy needs me
my little boy needs me if my daughter
ever looked for me
i would want the story to be told that
she never gave up
and if i were to die i would hate for
the story to be told to them is that
they weren't enough to keep me going
it's stupid to say like this but i could
never live with myself
if i knew that was the story to be told
to them if i had off to myself just
because it would be the easy way out
i could never ever do that ever
and i thank god for that that last
little glimmer of
wanting life i do that
because they need me in some way shape
or form i brought them into this world
to do something beautiful and i know
this for fact
i know this for a fact god didn't have
to give them to me
they didn't have to choose me to be
their mother
they didn't choose to be born into this
life either
but i know that there's nobody else that
could have done the job better than me
regardless of who i thought i was
i thought i was evil i thought it was
dark i didn't deserve anything good
at all i didn't i
i was really really cold and mean
to those who loved me i beat the girls
that i put on the streets
i beat them i packed a bowl and told the
kitchen i thought
we gotta we gotta pay for this room that
i didn't even stay in
work all day long to get into a room
just to be out all night i i was like a
storage
and those women are going through their
own battles
and they chose their life but i did not
help either
that's what i try to do today i come
here and i see these girls and everybody
on skid row and it breaks my heart
breaks my heart i have a really soft
spot for them i used to be there
we called it perkins and it's ventura
county skid row
they closed down this entire
and it's huge this entire private
property
because there were so many of us ex-cons
people on the run murderers drug dealers
everything we were all like the band of
thieves
everybody there the police couldn't [ __ ]
with us we were safe
we walked around from 10 to 10 with a
bong like a
a freaking pokeball and it was okay it
was normal
that was the life i thought i was
supposed to be i come here
it breaks my heart because i used to
love
going home i used to love it that was
freedom to me at the time
all of these people have put themselves
in their own personal jail
their own jail that they have made for
themselves a place of hell basically a
setting
that they think that they deserve or
they're stuck in but nobody's stuck
there
everybody has a choice not about what
happens to them but how they
proceed i can't control everything
but i can control what i do and i will
push myself all the way to the limit
and then let whoever or whatever
whoever you know whatever you believe in
i
i let them make it so if it's supposed
to be
i don't ever want to be the person out
there with no socks
and no shoes or a sock
put my asses out and i'm dirty and my
hair is padded
i don't want to be that person that's
talking to themself
i don't want to be that person that's
cutting themself i don't want to be that
person that's
sucking dick for a bowl and that's
i don't talk bad about them at all it is
that's what they need
at that moment that's what they feel
they can do
i can't i can't there's a million things
i could do better
i am a female macgyver i can do anything
and everything i can fix your car i can
i can teach you how to use the computer
i can do computer filings and everything
like that
i play instruments i do sign language
i've worked in the legal system i've
been in the legal system
i've been an advocate i've worked in the
food industry i have a food handlers
right now i just enrolled to go to
school for the first time go to college
and that i could have never dreamed of i
could have never
and i don't even know if i'm gonna be
able to do it because from a car
that's literally clinking clinking just
to
get to the gas station with my wife
driving it and taking herself to jail
for eight days i lost my mind
she just got out two days ago
she did those eight days and that same
day my wife
my mom took my son again
took my son and my dog
she went to jail and i lost all three of
them and i cried so hysterically
that my neighbors came and knocked on
the door to make sure i wasn't killing
anybody or killing myself it was so
terrible i was banging the walls i was
hitting myself i was breaking [ __ ]
i did not pick up though i didn't touch
weed
barely smoked a cigarette i didn't eat
didn't drink water i didn't sleep
other than that one night
for those eight days it was the hardest
time of my life it was also the last
eight days that i was allowed to be in
this apartment that i've been squatting
in for
six months with my family
as of yesterday i was
i'm officially homeless again i was
always homeless but i had this
make-believe fantasy that we built and
it was comfortable it was nice
and it would be nice if i really had
those things i really wish i could
have a bed and walk to the kitchen and
make breakfast for my son
and send my wife off to work like those
are normal things that i think that
everybody should enjoy
at least once in their life
i'm in this disgusting car and i recycle
every night
i have man hands i feel like i have this
forever stain on my nails that's just
like surrounding them
and it's only been in the last three
months that i've collected this
and they won't come off no matter how
scrub
this is why i don't even really try to
get cute
quote unquote because what's the point i
know i'm gonna get into a dumpster
later i gotta make the gas money you
know
we need gas we need food we need water
should be free i'm just saying
to steal just to live to shower
to have clean underground those are
little things to some people
they're huge to me huge
i can't tell you enough how many days i
went without food but i made sure that
my son had something at least
my son has never slept outside with me
he's never slept in the car with me
i always make sure he had a roof over
his head even if i didn't if i had a
standard playground
or the train tracks or the k'nex house
because that was my boyfriend at the
time and he took care of me
the stories i have and i know i've been
all over the place
and it's just there's so much i couldn't
there's no time in the world in a
lifetime to be able to like express
the stories and the emotion behind them
and how i've even survived this far i
shouldn't even be alive today
i shouldn't even be out of prison right
now
i shouldn't i'm grateful
i'm so grateful that i get to see the
beach and i get to see my son smile
i can hear my wife's laughter who just
did it 10 years in prison
god put me there to meet her god put me
there to find myself
god put me there to appreciate really
truly appreciate
my kids it's
a little too late to make up for lost
time
to try to heal any wounds or crazy glue
them together somehow
scotch tape however there's nothing that
could be done
i can only push forward and make sure
that something that i picked up i can
give away
to somebody anybody that will take it i
freely give it
we don't have to be stuck we don't we
don't have to
help i've seen people smoking dope and
still live a regular life
like regular not stealing or beating
people
hurting themselves whether it be
emotionally or physically
i've seen people functioning addicts
it's just a coping mechanism
of their own that they've been able to
shape perfectly for their life
i can't do that i can't for some reason
i can't find that key
i call it the easy button i can't
i once had it and i don't have it
anymore and i'm okay with that
i don't need that
i'm currently finding a case
for something i legitimately didn't do
for the first time in my life
i didn't do anything
and i'm out on bail my wife's on parole
and now summary probation we both don't
have licenses but we still drive because
it's the only way we can make a living
that car's not even in my name
i have the insurance at least in my name
it's the one responsible thing i did
every day every day i do something
illegal i make that choice
i try to pick the lesser of the evils as
far as my options go
but whether it's stealing food to eat or
literally the toothbrushes from this
morning that i had to get
to gas money from
people's cars you know when people leave
their cars unlocked i only take that
little bit of change that you leave
right there in the middle console
if your door's unlocked i don't break
your car i don't do anything i take that
change and i ankle
just for our gas just to go back and
forth to
do blood donations i donate plasma
twice a week i hate needles
it hurts so badly i'm exhausted
i feel like it takes like another piece
of me i know i'm saving somebody at the
end of it but
and i'm helping my family but thirty
dollars
for four hours of exhaustion and 12
hours of preparation for
it's not really worth it to me but it is
because when i get out and i have that
30
and i can buy that one pack of cigarette
we try to make stretch as far as we can
so that way i don't do anything else
and the gas money just to get back to
ventura to my son
those are things that i live for
i didn't even think i would do this far
but i
the most responsible irresponsible
person that you could
ever know and
as [ __ ] up as my life has been and as
[ __ ] up as i have been
it has humbled me it was the worst
tasting pie
ever nobody should ever
ever feel anything near what i've felt
ever ever
there's a million of us out there
different colors different
shapes different sizes and ages
different sexes everybody's felt it they
don't talk about it
everybody should open up i would feel so
much better if somebody told me that
they
they got molested by their father and he
left and never came back that day
and literally never came back i would
feel better about that
just because i didn't feel alone i hated
that you had to go through that
i hated that i went through a but damn
i'm not alone it's all just [ __ ] up
and scary and dark
there are so people are so [ __ ] mean
they are and they don't realize it
a simple good morning or not even as
anything just a smile
that changes my day smiles are
contagious
so why not give it freely
i say good morning as best i can even if
it's in spanish and i barely speak
anything
which is embarrassing but i do my best
i really hope i really hope that i
helped you in some way
in some kind of way i didn't even touch
on everything and that's okay like i
said there's not enough time but
i know that this helped me it really did
i feel so
light right now i felt a sense of calm
in some way and i felt it
since i saw the sheriff change the locks
on that door
and all my [ __ ] is still in that
apartment i have 18 days to get it
and i'm not even scared i don't know why
maybe it's because i've been here before
or because maybe i finally can breathe
because i know
this struggle better than i knew work
and paying rent on time
that life scares me i'm afraid to [ __ ]
up if i'm already at the bottom there's
no more room to [ __ ] up you know
i think that right there is why i feel
so good and my wife is freaking out
she's never been homeless before
she's never been homeless she was the
gang gang
big mind like super bad
she's always had everything whether she
stole or
sold drugs for it and beat people for it
didn't matter she always had it
fly j's fly 501's sexy haircut my wife
is sexy as [ __ ]
5-2 but sexy she's always had it
she doesn't she's been wearing the same
clothes since yesterday
she's tired and she's stressed out and
i'm calm
that's so sad i have to be our strength
right now
i have to get us out of this because she
deserves better she deserves to never
sleep in that dumb ass magnum of ours
right here on this block actually right
around the corner
she deserves better than that she
deserves it
she doesn't be in a bed so her back can
actually heal right
before she goes into surgery again
again i appreciate this i really do
because it's things like this that help
people heal
and move on even if they don't forgive
themselves
it helps us move forward and try to find
some kind of glimmer of hope
because we need that and earlier you
said things that
that were lacking as humans it's yes
there's integrity
but it's really it's just self and it's
it's a really simple word but there's so
much meaning behind it
there's self love there's self
confidence there's self understanding
self forgiveness that's my biggest
struggle
that's my biggest one but self
huge huge because you could say you
don't care
i don't give a [ __ ] that i called my mom
a [ __ ] i don't
there's a little girl inside me that
still calls her mommy
and still sees her as that beautiful
human being that
took care of four of us on her own
i love that woman she cared for my son
while i was in prison i could have lost
him
even though she took him from me for no
reason
at all i still love her
but i hate her and i don't know if it's
because i feel like she didn't
give me a chance she knew that that
chance wasn't given to her too
or it's because i seen that she didn't
have the right tools
and i didn't use them to my own
advantage
people make their choices i've seen
people out of the ghetto
gang families be doctors that's [ __ ]
amazing
i've seen people that were born into
rich families
go out there and do some of the darkest
things
we choose our paths it doesn't really
matter our upbringing it doesn't matter
what we're born into
technically it doesn't that's just to be
the starter everybody gets started on
their game board on their own place it
could be
all the way at the end [ __ ] good for you
[ __ ] yeah you never have to feel the
struggle
damn must be nice i'm not even jealous
[ __ ] yeah
or just started at the bottom and you
work your way up
that's okay i earned my [ __ ] whether
stolen or not
i always make up for it as best i can
yeah i
i am
grateful for my struggles like i said
with a smile i'm grateful for my
struggles because
not everyone can handle it some people
kill for it some people die over it
i live every day whether it's coming or
not and i know it is
i'm grateful because it gives me a
sense of hope for the better it can't
get no worse
and if it did guess what it's gonna
[ __ ] pass again and it's gonna
[ __ ] pass again and it's always gonna
be like that so that's my repetition
i understand that now it is what it is
one day i will get it together and it
will be beautiful and i can't wait to
tell that story
i'll get there i know i will it's gonna
be a minute but i'll get there
that day would be the most beautiful day
ever
i'll have the biggest smile
i just want to say thank you to all the
people that [ __ ] me up
i love myself today i'm [ __ ] awesome
it could be worse thank you
helps the talker oh god yes